by now I'm sure you've heard about
Amazon getting sued the FDC and 17
states have sued Amazon for maintaining
an illegal Monopoly within the
e-commerce Market the outcome of this
case could very well be Amazon getting
split up into not just two companies but
several companies also it's not just
Amazon that would be affected as this
case would very much set a president for
all of big Tech in general potentially
leading to even more breakups and
landmark cases this idea of Amazon
finally being held accountable has made
much of the internet quite happy because
let's be honest Amazon is definitely a
monopoly last year nearly 60% of all
online retail purchases were made on
Amazon if that's not a monopoly I don't
know what is but this doesn't have to be
bad news for Amazon in fact this lawsuit
could turn into the best thing that ever
happened to Amazon here's the thing
whether you or me or the entire world
believes that Amazon is a monopoly is
for the most part completely irrelevant
all that matters is whether that
argument actually holds up within the
court of law and let me just say Amazon
has a far better chance at court than
they do with public opinion as Amazon
put it while it's true that most online
retail purchases come through them they
don't exactly end up with them in fact
Amazon claims that they're supporting
500,000 independent businesses and 1.5
million jobs within the US alone with
that being said Amazon would have
definitely preferred for this case to
never come up in the first place but at
the same time they likely knew that it
was inevitable and they can very much
use this to their favor here's the thing
if Amazon is able to come out on top
with this case no prosecutor would
likely touch them for the next 20 to 30
years in other words winning this case
would basically give them a free pass to
keep doing exactly what they're doing
with little fear of legal repercussions
don't believe me well join me as we take
a look back at landmark cases that show
that this case could just as easily go
Amazon's
way speaking of monopolies if you'd like
to help us take on the big Bank Monopoly
and earn 4 to 7% yields in the meantime
check out our upcoming Bond investing
app Silo in the description below but
anyway getting straight into it if
you've been watching this channel for a
while you probably already know what
case I'm going to talk about it's none
other than the landmark case United
States versus Microsoft if you're not
familiar with this case this was
probably before your time but
essentially this case was a daring bit
to break up Microsoft into two companies
one that sold operating systems and one
that sold other pieces of software like
Internet Explorer Microsoft Office mson
messenger and so on the roots of this
case date back to the mid 1990s when the
internet was just starting to become a
thing the go-to browser for 90% of
Internet users was something called
Netscape Navigator so Netscape was very
much a monopoly which Microsoft wasn't
exactly a fan of you may not have known
this but these companies only like it
when they're the monopo so on August
16th 1995 Microsoft decided to take
things into their own hands by launching
Internet Explorer given Microsoft's vast
resources putting together a functional
browser wasn't particularly hard but
getting people to use it man that was
difficult fortunately though Microsoft
had a sneaky plan to get around this
little conundrum everyone already had
Windows computers so what if Microsoft
just bundled an iie with windows that
should give I a massive boost in
popularity straight out the window right
well there was one fatal flaw with this
plan it was illegal you see the doj had
already seen this coming they saw
Microsoft do this with office and they
had since put a deal in place that would
prevent Microsoft from ever doing it
again there was one caveat to this deal
though Microsoft wasn't allowed to
bundle in products with Windows but they
were allowed to bundle in features so
Microsoft would just call IE a feature
and bundle it in with Windows obviously
everyone in the entire world knows that
iie is a product and that this is in
violation of their previous doj
settlement but Microsoft probably just
thought we can roll a dice with an
antitrust lawsuit if it ever came to it
and guess what it would come to it on
May 18th 1998 the doj anded 20 States
would file an antitrust lawsuit against
Microsoft just like what we're seeing
right now with Amazon the case would
drag on for about 2 years and both
Microsoft and the doj would have their
own shair of Victories and losses but at
the end of the day the doj would Prevail
on June 7th 2000 Microsoft would
officially be order to split up into two
different companies naturally most
people thought that this was the end of
it Microsoft was a monopo they knew it
the doj knew it the whole world knew it
and now it was made official and it was
time for Microsoft to face the music
unfortunately though it didn't end up
playing out like this instead Microsoft
would appeal to the Supreme Court and
they would end up overturning this
decision over a legal technicality you
see the judge that was overseeing this
case had regularly made statements to
the media because the public wanted to
stay up toate and Microsoft would end up
arguing that his statements to the media
suggested that he was biased against
Microsoft the Supreme Court would end up
ruling that the judge's findings and
conclusions were all well and good
however due to apparent bias his final
ruling was not and as such Microsoft
would be allowed to settle let me put
this another way the doj literally
proved that Microsoft was a monopoly in
court and Microsoft still wasn't broken
up because of a legal technicality that
likely not even Microsoft cared about as
far as they were concerned this was just
a loophole to get out of the situation
and it worked fast forward 23 years and
not only is Microsoft 10 times bigger
but there's still a bundling edge with
windows so just because a massive cases
filed against Amazon doesn't mean
anything as far as we know a judge could
Point Blank rule for Amazon to be broken
up and it could still go the other way
until they're actually broken up they're
not but even on the off chance that they
do get broken up it probably wouldn't
matter all that much anyway let me
explain a lot of people seem to think
that breaking up a monopoly such as
Amazon is exactly the solution we need
but in reality this is isn't all that
effective in fact I would argue that
it's for the most part ineffective and
we've seen this repeatedly throughout
history starting with Standard Oil
Standard Oil was the brainchild of oil
Pioneer John D Rockefeller and it was
definitely a monopoly going into the
1900s Standard Oil controlled 91% of oil
production and 85% of final sales in the
United States so in 1906 Uncle Sam
decided to step in and teach Standard
Oil a lesson the case would drag on for
5 years but eventually prosecutors would
get their way in 1911 Standard Oil would
be split up not just into one or two or
even five companies they would be split
up into 34 separate entities surely such
a drastic action would neutralize the
company because they would have to
compete against each other right well it
actually did the exact opposite you see
the leaders of these companies may have
had internal cont conflicts amongst
themselves before the split up but after
the split up they were more united than
ever the situation had changed from you
versus me to US versus the world this
was also around the time that the Ford
Model T would go viral meaning that more
people than ever needed oil and instead
of fighting over these customers
standard oil companies would unite and
dominate the market together investors
would do the exact same thing now that
the Anti-Trust Cloud wasn't looming over
Standard Oil in invers would be far more
willing to invest and if you don't
believe me just look at the facts in the
10 years following the breakup the
combined value of the 34 companies
didn't just grow it quintupled this took
Rockefeller from being a mere moral
worth $300 million to being the world's
first billionaire the irony of this is
insane the case that was supposed to put
a decisive end to people like
Rockefeller literally ended up creating
the world's first billionaire and it
didn't just stop right there either
eventually the strongest of these
companies would make their Partnerships
official and merge to create Exxon
Chevron and BP and over a 100 years
after their breakup these three are
still part of the top 10 oil companies
with a combined market value of just
under $8
trillion now you might be inclined to
say that this was just a fluke and that
standard oil just got lucky which brings
us into our next land Mark lawsuit
United States versus AT&T back in the
1970s AT&T found themselves controlling
90% of the US telephone business seeing
this Uncle Sam decided that it was time
to put an end to this disgusting
Monopoly after an 8-year law suit in
1982 AT&T would agree to split up their
business into seven smaller Regional
businesses called baby bells surely this
would pit these companies against each
other and lead to a competitive
landscape but once again the exact
opposite happened the baby bells would
end up joining forces in record of time
here's a flowchart of exactly what
happened the baby bells would basically
just unite to create AT&T and Verizon
the two players who still dominate the
US telecommunications industry to this
day I do want to note that T-Mobile was
able to make a name for themselves
during this time period but it wasn't
because of the breakup it was because
there was a new market Wireless
telecommunications which for new
competition to capitalize on not to
mention T-Mobile was backed by the
German telecommunications Monopoly
Deutsche Telecom so it wasn't really a
case of the underdog taking on Verizon
and AT&T it was actually just a case of
an international Monopoly taking on two
national monopolies and together they
still control the entire market so who
knows breaking up Monopoly may actually
play out better for Amazon over the long
term instead of being worth the mere
$150 billion Jeff Bezos could become
become the world's first trillionaire
Jokes Aside though just like an
Anti-Trust lawsuit isn't necessarily a
nail in the coffin a breakup isn't
[Music]
either at the end of the day Amazon is a
trillion dollar Corporation and you can
bet that they're going to show up to
court with the absolute best lawyers in
the world but not only are these lawyers
skilled they'll be far more incentivized
to win Federal prosecutors are at best
paid $183,000 for their efforts so
winning has more to do with principle
and the justice of taking down the bully
than monetary gain Amazon's lawyers on
the other hand are literally paid tens
of millions and you can bet that they're
going to get a ridiculous $50 or $100
million bonus if they're able to come
out Victorious not to mention it history
has shown us that it's extremely
difficult to break up one of these
companies they don't even need to prove
that they're not a monopoly
even illegal technicality is enough to
throw out the entire case regardless of
their guilt and with this much at stake
who knows what Amazon's lawyers will
uncover but even if they lose and Amazon
somehow gets broken up it doesn't really
matter all that much anyway all of
Amazon's investors including Jeff Bezos
will just own both companies which could
allow them to grow to even larger
Heights now none of this is to say that
Amazon is destined to be a monopoly
forever though in fact Jeff Bezos would
be the first one to admit that Amazon
isn't going to last forever have short
lifespans Charlie and Amazon will be
disrupted one day then you worry about
that I don't worry about it cuz I know
it's inevitable companies come and go
and the companies that are the shinest
and most important of any era you wait a
few decades and they're gone and your
job is to make sure that you delay that
date i' sure I would love for it to be
after I'm
dead but monopolies like Amazon aren't
taken down by litigation or government
action monopolies are a monopoly for a
reason it's not because these companies
are so smart or because they have so
much power or any of that it's because
their current value in the marketplace
is simply indispensable splitting up
such a company wouldn't change that the
only way that such monopolies are
destroyed is by an extreme Market shift
when the next revolutionary shopping
platform comes out and Amazon is no
longer indispensable until that happens
though any noise like this lawsuit can't
really hurt them whether it's successful
or not if anything it just gives them an
opportunity to clear their name
officially and double down with these
types of lawsuits the public is usually
rooting against the big tech company but
not too long ago the public was actually
rooting for Google to win a lawsuit
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Harry and I'll see you
guys on the next
[Music]
one